in this lesson we're going to talk about
combining like terms so the makers of
the SKT apparently want you to
understand how to work with this concept
so we're going to go through here it's
pretty easy but you just want to make
sure you don't make a little error so
let's go through a couple examples see
if you can do these on your own will go
through them together the first one says
which of the following is equivalent to
this quantity minus this quantity right
let me give us some multiple choice
answers so go ahead and pause the video
if you can do this on your own and we'll
go through it together so the first
thing I would do is see when you
subtract so tractions really like adding
the opposite so what I did is instead of
subtracting I just added the opposite i
changed all these signs in the
parentheses outfit it's also like
distributing a negative one so now it's
a little bit easier because instead of
subtracting yours adding so we can get
right into the combining like terms
we've got a QB there's no other a cube
bees here so I'm just going to bring
that down we've got a negative for a B
and a negative 2 ad which adds up to a
negative 6a be right so we're just
adding the coefficients and then here
we've got a for a there's does look like
there's any a's over here so i'm just
going to bring that down plus 4a it's
got 3 b squared plus 1 b squared which
is 4b squared right and i know there's
one because you don't see it coefficient
in front i just means there's one of
them so 1 plus 3 is for that looks like
that's our final answer so the best
dancer here looks like it's going to be
letter C okay now example 25 y times 4y
plus 2 minus 3 times 2y minus 7 equals
ax squared plus BX plus C if a B and C
are constants what is the value of C
okay this one right here so basically
what they're asking us to do is to
simplify this expression and then set it
equal to what's on the right there and
find out what this caste of sea is so go
ahead and pause the video so you can do
this one on your own and we'll go
through it together so basically what
we're doing here is we're distributing
the five Y into the parentheses and here
this is like a minus three but you can
think of it as like a negative 3 you're
distrib
being that inside the parentheses so 5y
times 4y gives us 20 y squared plus 5y
times two is ten y distribute the
negative three that's going to give you
negative 6y negative three times
negative 7 is 21 and then now we're
going to combine like terms so this
gives us 20 y squared plus 4y plus 21 21
okay is our constant you can see four
would be our B value and then 20 would
be our a value but the answer here
they're looking for C so it's going to
be 21 that's your solution so combining
like terms it's an important concept to
understand go ahead and review this
lesson if you need to otherwise i'll see
you in the next lesson